Tim Ferriss: Hello, boys and girls, ladies and
germs, this is Tim Ferriss. Welcome to another
episode of The Tim Ferriss Show. I'm going to
skip my preamble to get to the guest today, Niall
Ferguson. You can find him on Twitter @nfergus,
F-E-R-G-U-S. MA, DPhil, FRSE—we may get into
what that is—is the Millbank Family Senior Fellow
at the Hoover Institution, Stanford University,
and a senior faculty fellow of the Belfer Center
for Science and International Affairs at Harvard.
He's the author of 16 books, good Lord, that's
a lot of books, including The Pity of War,
The House of Rothschild, Empire, Civilization,
and Kissinger, 1923-1968: The Idealist,
which won the Council on Foreign Relations Arthur
Ross Prize. He's an award-winning filmmaker too,
having won an international Emmy for his PBS
series The Ascent of Money. His 2018 book,
The Square and the Tower, was a New York Times
bestseller and also adapted for television
by PBS as Niall Ferguson’s Networld.
In 2020, he joined Bloomberg Opinion
as a columnist. In addition, he is the founder
and managing director of Greenmantle LLC, a New
York based advisory firm, a co-founder of Ualá,
a Latin American financial technology company,
and a trustee of The New York Historical Society,
the London Based Center for Policy Studies,
and the newly founded University of
Austin. His latest book, Doom, subtitled,
The Politics of Catastrophe, was published
last year by Penguin and was shortlisted for
the Lionel Gerber Prize. Niall, so nice
to see you. Thanks for making the time.
Niall Ferguson: Good to be with you, Tim.
And guilty as charged, all that you just
said is true and I cannot deny it.
Tim Ferriss: All of the things and
we are going to unpack all sorts of bits and
pieces of that. And I wanted to start with
an observation, and you can correct this
observation if it's an illusion, a mirage,
a misreading of the facts. Noah Feldman
says hello, by the way, as a side note and —
Niall Ferguson: Hello back to Noah.
Tim Ferriss: And that is, he put into words
something that has struck me about your career and
that is that it's not really one career. You have
at least three careers, so a major historian, so
the best of the best, played the ivory tower game
brilliantly well, then public historian/public
intellectual, we could parse out or relabel any
number of those. And then afterwards, you have
advisory firms and the company involvement and
so on. The first question I want to ask related to
this, and certainly you can revise that, but what
was your first experience in reaching a broader
public with your ideas, outside of academia?
Niall Ferguson: I always felt that if I was going
to be a historian, it should not be for some
tiny exclusive audience confined to ivory towers,
whether in Oxford or Cambridge or Harvard. My hero
when I was a schoolboy was a British historian,
A.J.P. Taylor, who not only wrote terrific books,
I think the first history book I remember
engaging with was his illustrated history
of the First World War. But he also would write
newspaper columns and do lectures on television
and get into public rows. And that always
struck me as a highly attractive way of life.
You would be in the morning sitting in your
oak paneled study, surrounded by books,
smoking your pipe and giving tutorials. But in
the afternoon, you'd bash out 1,000 words for The
Daily Express, and then you'd deliver a quick
lecture on the 1848 Revolutions for the BBC,
and then you'd be in time for a high table at
seven. That was always the plan. I never aspired
to be a dry as dust academic at all. In fact,
it's striking how successful I've executed a
plan that I hatched when I was a teenager.
Tim Ferriss: This leads into, I suppose
the question maybe even part answered it,
which is, let me set the table by saying,
I have a lot of involvement with friends
in academia, with researchers who are
de facto involved in academic settings, and
there's a lot of fear-based career planning
in those circles, sort of seeking a prestige and
social support or endorsement. You seem to have
been a skeptic of whatever container people
have attempted to put you within and have
become an iconoclast in many respects. Is that
lack of fear, what appears to be a lack of fear,
something that was developed? Is it simply
because you had already hatched a plan to
leave the confines, for instance, in the one case
of academia, therefore you weren't worried about
them booting you out. Where does that openness
to criticizing what's around you come from?
Niall Ferguson: Well, you have to remember
that I'm old, I'm 58. When my career —
Tim Ferriss: You've been at it for a while though.
Niall Ferguson: Yeah, but the launch zone in the
mid 1980s when I was an undergraduate at Oxford,
was very different compared with the launch zone
at a Harvard or a Yale or a Stanford today. And
I'm not sure it's possible to be me today. In
fact, it almost certainly isn't. We forget that
the 1980s were a high point of academic freedom,
because academic freedom's not something that's
always been there, it had to kind of be fought
for, in the later 20th Century. And I was one
of the beneficiaries of a tremendous climate
of intellectual freedom in Britain in the '80s.
The battles had really been fought in the '60s
and '70s or earlier. And we took for granted
that we could say the most outrageous things,
calculatedly offensive things, and pay no price.
I used to call myself a punktory, because I had
been a schoolboy when the Sex Pistols burst onto
the scene in 1976. Three years later, Margaret
Thatcher became Prime Minister and she was almost
as infuriating to many people as Johnny Rotten.
And I loved that. I just loved the fact
the Sex Pistols shook up music and she
shook up politics. And I arrived at Oxford
in the early '80s at the same time as my old
friend Andrew Sullivan. And we were just
odious. We were just the most obnoxious,
the most obnoxious young men. And we took pride
in our outrageous discourse, as it would be called
today. There was a famous occasion when somebody
threw a, well it wasn't famous, it was famous to
us, somebody threw a party to celebrate the
deployment of cruise and Pershing missiles
to Western Europe. And the invitation was the
neck of a champagne bottle with a mushroom cloud
coming out of it. And that was one of the milder
things that we did. At that time, there were very
limited downside risks to being obnoxious
and I think that was true in the US too.
I said to Peter Thiel the other day, "You couldn't
be you now. 18-year-old Peter Thiel now would
be kind of destroyed on the launchpad, whereas
you could be as obnoxious as we were at Oxford,
at Stanford, and actually positively benefit
from it." There were some risks to going
into the academic profession even then though,
because there's a period in your academic career,
even in the 1980s, when you're capable
of being destroyed on the launchpad,
because you do need people to write letters of
reference and you do need committees to give you
jobs and you need them also to agree to publish
your first book, all that stuff. And so I'll give
you an example of my risk averse behavior. I
did a lot of journalism in the '80s when I was
a graduate student. I couldn't have afforded to
do a PhD otherwise because I really had no money
beyond a very meager scholarship.
And I was doing research in Germany, which
was quite expensive in those days for a British
student. And so I did a lot of journalism, but I
did it under assumed names. There was a chap named
Alec Campbell. There was F.F. Gillespie who wrote
for Punch magazine. And for several years, I led a
double life, where Niall Ferguson was the somewhat
right-leaning, but terribly rigorous scholar,
but these other personas would be writing,
even for the Daily Mail, which was a really
scandalous thing for an aspiring academic
to do. And I would say, I can remember
quite early on, an old rival of mine,
going around telling everybody that in fact, Alec
Campbell was me and those wire why pieces in the
Daily Mail were by me, and I probably —
Tim Ferriss: Pause for a second —
Niall Ferguson: He thought that
would kill me and it didn't.
Tim Ferriss: What was the blood feud between
you and this arch rival? What was he hoping to
gain? Was he hoping to gain from this or just
simply annihilate you by outing this scandal
of identity flak jackets that you've been using?
Niall Ferguson: Well, Maurice Cowling, one of the
great conservative historians of Cambridge, once
characterized the three virtues in life as irony,
geniality, and malice and I think my contemporary
was motivated by all three. It wasn't that he was
meditating career extinction, it was just a
combination of irony, geniality, and malice.
He presumably was sitting at high table and there
was a lull of the conversation and he said, "Oh,
by the way, did you know that that awful Alec
Campbell in the Daily Mail is really Niall
Ferguson?" And I do remember being seized by panic
when I realized that he'd outed me. But by that
point, I think I'd got far enough up the ladder —
Tim Ferriss: You've reached
escape velocity on some level.
Niall Ferguson: Just about, or maybe there's
another theory about this, which I'll briefly
share. In those days, you've got to remember
that before the internet, communications
were really quite terrible in the horizontal
domain. You had vertical communication, you could
listen to the BBC if they didn't ban your single,
you could do that. But Oxford and Cambridge didn't
communicate very much. And so you could be outed
in Oxford but still get a job in Cambridge
because the news have not in fact traveled
across the country in the same way that my mentor,
Norman Stone got a job in Oxford, despite having
behaved quite outrageously in Cambridge. But his
Cambridge backers were really trying to export
him to Oxford, so they perjured themselves in
their letters of reference. And no one in Oxford
really bothered to pick up a phone and say, "Is
any of this true?" I think what really happened
was that I was outed in Oxford, but in the
nick of time, got a job in Cambridge and was
able to start a new life with a clean sheet.
Tim Ferriss: I'm going to make a confession
as a knuckle-dragging Long Islander.
I don't actually know what high table
is or the high table. I can imagine in my
mind some British high society function,
maybe with some fantastic adult beverages. But
what image should high table conjure in my mind?
Niall Ferguson: Well, you're right
about the beverages. You've watched
some Harry Potter movies.
Tim Ferriss: I have, yes.
Niall Ferguson: That's all you need to know.
It's basically the case that Hogwarts is a
sort of entertaining amalgam of Eaton and an
Oxford College, quite a lot of it's actually
shot at Christ Church. And you'll remember
that when they have their spectacular feasts,
the teachers sit on a slightly elevated dais
with a big long table. And not Gandalf, wrong —
Tim Ferriss: It does look like whiskers.
Niall Ferguson: I get Dumble —
Tim Ferriss: Dumbledore.
Niall Ferguson: Dumbledore, I get my
children's fiction confused because I have to
watch so much of it. Dumbledore gives his speeches
from that high table. And if you go to dinner at
Christ Church, essentially you will see a version
of Hogwarts, slightly less visually striking,
but the same basic idea. And the thing that's
attractive about Ox and Cambridge, if you come
from Glasgow, remember, you think Long Island is—
Tim Ferriss: A backwater?
Niall Ferguson: —low?
Let me tell you about Glasgow.
I came from what was once one of the
great industrial metropoles of the British Empire,
but by the 1970s was Rust Belt. We were doing
Hillbilly Elegy before J.D. Vance was even born, I
think. And it was quite a messy place. And Oxford,
by comparison, just looked like a really high-end
BBC costume drama, in which the men wore tweed
suits and they dined at high table. And at high
table the most delicious wines were served.
And all of this was irresistibly attractive
to me when I was a teenager. I thought,
"I'm going to get out of Glasgow and I'm going
to have a study like that and I'm going to eat
at high table and wear a tweed suit,"
and I did those things and it was great.
Tim Ferriss: Did it live up to the dreams?
Niall Ferguson: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: What did you like about it?
Niall Ferguson: In those days, when I made
it first to high table, it was in Cambridge
and I was at Christ's College that had been
immortalized in a novel, The Masters, by C.P. Snow
in which Cambridge politics provides the drama and
academic politics has its own peculiar appeal as
Henry Kissinger famously said, "It's so poisonous
because the stakes are so low," very good line.
Tim Ferriss: Now you are actually of good
authority to say, did Kissinger also say, "I left
academics because I couldn't stand the politics,"
something along those lines. Or is that just one
of those attributed to Abraham Lincoln or Oscar
Wilde quotes floating around on the internet?
Niall Ferguson: Oh no, Kissinger has said so
many things that you deny he said something and
the next day you find it in one of the documents,
so he probably said that, but it certainly fits.
But I got to Christ's and there were in fact
three masters, two former masters and one current
serving master, regularly dining at high table.
And the vicious way in which the former masters
undermined the serving master was my introduction
to academic politics. Luckily one of the former
masters was Sir John Plumb, Jack Plumb, a very
influential historian of that generation. He had
come from humble origins in the town of Leicester,
but had risen through the academic ranks, had
been involved at Bletchley Park during the war,
had got to know the Rothschild family and
had been introduced to the delights of
Château Lafite by the Rothschilds and he used
to serve Château Lafite at special occasions —
Tim Ferriss: This is the nice wine I assume?
Niall Ferguson: It's one of the great Bordeaux.
Tim Ferriss: Oh my goodness, of course.
Niall Ferguson: Not available in Long Island,
but I'm in Glasgow, but available in Cambridge.
And so I fell in with him and he would on his
85th birthday, serve some fantastic vintage. And
the younger dons, the engineering fellows would
sort of take a couple of sips and then leave most
of it undrunk and go back to the laboratories.
And this would send Jack into a rage, he would
seethe. He was a very cantankerous old man. And I,
as the junior-most fellow, I remember on one
occasion I was such a shameless sycophant,
but also with a taste for Château Lafite. I said
after they'd all gone, I said, "Jack, it's a
terrible shame to waste this wine. I'm going to
drink the dregs from the glasses that they've
left." And he loved me for that. And I also lived
to tell the tale. None of them had any obviously
lethal infectious diseases. And it's the most
wonderful wine. And once you've drunk Lafite, it's
hard to go back to what you were drinking before.
Tim Ferriss: You're spoiled, spoiled for life.
That scene should make it into a screenplay
at the turn of some act, that is a fantastic
scene. "May I drink the dregs?"
Niall Ferguson: It was a good —
Tim Ferriss: "Would it please you
if I were to drink the dregs?"
Niall Ferguson: It was a good move because Jack
Plumb was one of the great academic patrons.
Simon Schama was one of Jack's proteges and
Linda Colley. And so by sucking up to Jack,
I did my career no harm at all. Because
when Jack wrote a reference, when he wrote
a letter of reference, he would begin, "Not
since Edward Gibbon has a historian written
at this level of quality." Wildly hyperbolic
references. Yeah, academic politics involves
that kind of odious behavior. And I'm afraid
I was capable of it in my twenties. Still am.
Tim Ferriss: Skilled, one might say. Let's go
back to A.J.P. Taylor. Number of questions about
A.J.P. Taylor. I had never heard this name, I'm
ashamed to admit, until doing some research for
this conversation. And number of questions again
with the baseline of Long Island kept in mind,
because these are probably going to be
fairly one-on-one questions. One is,
how should people think about defining philosophy
of history? That's number one. And number two
is the Taylor line related to historical
sensibility being similar to musical sensibility,
and if you could just say more about that.
Niall Ferguson: The philosophy of history
is barely studied or indeed taught. And yet you
can't really be an historian without a philosophy
of history. You have to understand the nature of
causation. These days, nobody bothers with that,
which is why a lot of academic history is garbage.
I became fascinated by the philosophy of history
at that time when I was drinking Château Lafite
with Jack Plumb and realized that there was a
very central problem, namely that any causal
statement, this is obvious to philosophers
and it's obvious to people who do the law,
implies a counterfactual. In other words,
if we say that the conversation between Tim
Ferriss and Niall Ferguson in November 2022
led to the outbreak of war between China
and the United States the following year,
that implies that if we
hadn't had the conversation,
the war wouldn't have happened. And so the
what-if question, "Well, what if they hadn't
had the conversation?" is a legitimate question.
In the same way, if you think that Hitler was the
key architect of World War II and it wouldn't have
happened without him, then it's legitimate to ask,
"What would've happened if Hitler had in
fact been assassinated prior to September
1939?" Those what-if questions were of great
importance to me as a young scholar and teacher,
that was how I used to teach students. I would
say, "Well what if that hadn't happened? What
if Britain hadn't intervened in 1914?" Taylor was
a historian who was sympathetic to that approach.
His view was a somewhat skeptical, ironical view
that men only learn from history how to make new
mistakes. And his books are shot through with the
role of contingency. One of the things that made
Taylor attractive to me in parentheses, was his
brilliant pro style up there with George Orwell as
one of the master stylists of the 20th Century.
And a tremendous master of paradox
and of one-liners too. The line about the
1848 revolutions as being the turning point
when Germany failed to turn. All that stuff I
found exciting because being able to write like
that is also the way to convince a reader,
to be able to talk like that is to convince
an audience, so that's how the philosophy
of history relates to the style of history.
The second question that you asked about music,
his assertion that the historical sensibility is
a bit like the receptiveness to music is right.
History's not a science. It can't be a science
because we can't rerun events in laboratory and
see if, consistently, war breaks out in 1939 with
or without Hitler. So what we're doing when we
studied the past as a great Oxford philosopher
of history, R.G. Collingwood said, is, "We're
kind of reconstituting past human experience
from the bits and pieces that have been left
behind. And as we do that, it's a very subtle
process of mental reenactment of experience."
And I'm not sure that Taylor was wrong to compare
it to that musical side of the human psyche.
Interestingly, as someone else said much the same
thing, a man named Fritz Kraemer, who was Henry
Kissinger's great mentor during and after World
War II and Kraemer said that Kissinger had this
kind of sensibility. He was attuned to history. I
think that's very, very right. You've got to have
that the ear for it. And it's quite obvious when
one reads a book when a historian's tone deaf and
shouldn't really have gone into the business, just
as it would be obvious if they tried to conduct
an orchestra or play a concerto. Yeah, I think
it's much closer to music than it is to science.
Tim Ferriss: How does that show up for you having
a trained ear in historical resonance, let's just
say, the ear for history. How does that show up
when it is part of an author's constitution
or developed repertoire? What does it look
like in their writing or their thinking?
Niall Ferguson: When I was writing the
history of the Rothschild banks
and family back in the 1990s,
I spent a lot of my time reading through dusty old
letters and diary entries and minutes of meetings.
And the most striking documents were the
letters that the Rothschild brothers wrote
to one another. There were five of them.
They'd come out of the Frankfurt ghetto.
They had built, within an amazingly short time,
the most powerful financial institution in Europe,
already by the 1820s. And they wrote almost
daily to one another because they no longer
lived together. One was in London, one was in
Paris, one was in Vienna, one was in Naples,
and one was in Frankfurt. And so these
letters were almost more like phone calls
and they were extremely hard to decipher
because they wrote in Hebrew characters,
which were extremely difficult to read, even if
you knew Hebrew. The only way I could access the
letters was to have a scholar who could read
them, a wonderful man named Mordechai Zucker,
read them aloud onto audio cassettes.
And so I spent a lot of time listening to
these letters. And when he read them aloud, they
were mostly German with occasional Hebrew words.
They were electrifying documents. They cast
an entirely new light on the 19th Century and
they were entirely absorbing, not least
because they were so regular, so it was very
high frequency correspondence. And I can remember
one letter, and I'll never forget the experience
of hearing it, in which the eldest of the brothers
whose name was Amschel, described what it was like
for the first time to own land. He bought a garden
on the outskirts of Frankfurt. Prior to that,
Jews had not been allowed to own real estate.
And he, as a result of the upheavals caused
by the French Revolution, suddenly was able to
do that. And he writes to the brothers saying,
"I bought the garden. And last night I
slept in it. I slept outside in the garden."
And he described the feeling, and I remember, and
it still makes my spine tingle, the feeling of
excitement that this quite dry man — because he
was almost had the mentality of the accountant
amongst the brothers — but this quite dry
man had done that. He'd slept outdoors for
the first time in a garden that he owned. And I
was moved to tears and I thought, "What is this
like? Why is this such a moving document?" And I
remembered the moment in Beethoven's "Fidelio,"
when the prisoners are let out into the open
air, he actually uses the expression “freier
Luft”—”free air”—and that prisoner's chorus,
when they sing what it is to be in the open air,
struck me as exactly the appropriate music
for that moment. And I remember putting it on
my then stereo player and listening to Beethoven
and listening again to the letter and thinking,
"This is an enormously important document
which captures what emancipation means,
what it is to be suddenly given a civil
right that you've previously been denied."
And often in my career, I've had these epiphanies,
moments when a document suddenly reveals something
profound and often that moment of connection has a
musical dimension to it. The best historians have
that ability to bring the experiences of the
dead alive, bring them back to life, make you
empathize with them despite the distance in time
and in space and in experience. And that's a hard
thing to do. And not many people can do it well.
Indeed, many historians these days don't even
try because they don't feel that our mission is
to reconstitute past experience. They feel that
our mission is to go back and judge people in
the past for their sins by our standards. And
that means that there's a project which I think
is very hostile to historical understanding, to
change the mission of the historian, instead
of trying to reconstitute past experience,
we are really just sitting there, passing
judgments on past actions. I'm very against
that. I think it produces very bad history.
It also produces quite boring history.
Tim Ferriss: If we go back to
A.J.P., what did A.J.P. stand
for? Actually, I should know this, but —
Niall Ferguson: AlanTaylor, I forget —
Tim Ferriss: Alan.
Niall Ferguson: — probably John Percivale,
but I might be wrong. But he was known as
Alan to his intimates. But in those days,
people quite often published with only their
initials, created perhaps a certain distance
between the author and the public. I never
contemplated being N.C. Ferguson, though.
It's just too off-putting, isn't it?
Tim Ferriss: Non-Commissioned Officer
Ferguson. I do like it, though. Dr. Taylor
said, as you mentioned, mentally learned from
history how to make new mistakes. Now he seems,
I don't know this person at all, but as you
describe, being a master of paradox, also being
a wordsmith and gifted in that particular way,
that there may be some truth in this statement,
but he also dedicated his life to history. If you
got a few drinks, a few glasses of Château Lafite
into Dr. Taylor and said, "All right, look, I
know that's a great line, but why is history
important to you? Why have you dedicated your life
to this?" How do you think he might answer that?
Niall Ferguson: I'm pretty sure he was Mr.
Taylor, in those days, people didn't bother
getting doctorates.
Tim Ferriss: Just —
Niall Ferguson: They were regarded as —
Tim Ferriss: I'm using "doctor" more
in the Dr. Seuss capacity.
Niall Ferguson: The English
regarded doctorates as a German invention
that one didn't need to sully one's life with.
Tim Ferriss: Mr. Taylor.
Niall Ferguson: Perhaps wisely.
Taylor's conviction was that most people thought
wrongly about the past, had misconceptions about
it, and these misconceptions led them into
error. One of the most controversial books
he ever wrote was a book on the origins of
the Second World War, in which he argued very
paradoxically as a contrarian that really Hitler
had not been a particularly unusual German leader
and that Hitler's foreign policy had in some
ways been the continuation of previous foreign
policies, and that the war was really the fault
of the blundering incompetents in London and Paris
who had made the policy of appeasement and had
pursued it very ineptly. The book is still worth
reading even although these days, most people
would disagree with Taylor because they would
argue, as I would argue, that Hitler was a kind
of monster whose ideology and whose personality
were very unusual and a departure from German
tradition. At any event, the book is brilliant
and it's designed to force you to reassess your
assumptions about why World War II happened.
I'm motivated by the same belief that most people
think wrong things about the past and base their
actions on these erroneous assumptions. And
the job of the historian is to challenge the
conventional wisdom about past events in
the belief that the conventional wisdom's
actually quite a dangerous thing. So it's to me
uninteresting to write a book that essentially
repeats the arguments that have been made before.
I have no motivation to write a book unless it's
challenging what people have thought about the
past, whether it's the origins of the First World
War, which I wrote a book about, whether it's the
nature of 20th century conflict, whether it's the
history of money. Whatever it is, I'm motivated
to say something that challenges received opinion
in the belief that by doing that, I might possibly
improve decision-making in the present and future.
I believe, and I've always believed, that we
are trying to learn lessons from the past.
And when Taylor said that men only learn
from the past how to make new mistakes,
he wasn't dismissing the possibility of learning
from history, but he was being ironical.
It's probably right that no matter how hard we
try, we'll end up making new mistakes. But that's
not a counsel of despair. And I passionately
believe that the study of history must be
motivated by a desire to do better or at least
to fail better next time. So that I think is what
you'd have got from Taylor if you'd plied him with
Château Lafite, although Taylor would've resisted
your very American impulse to get a sincere
answer. And I am enough of an American now
to give sincere answers, but the typical
British dawn of Taylor's generation would've
just — he would not have been able to
resist the temptation to tease you.
Tim Ferriss: Maybe I need more of that. Maybe
I should spend more time at the high table.
Niall Ferguson: I can arrange that.
Tim Ferriss: You have given me an
appetite for some tweed, I will be honest.
Niall Ferguson: It's good in winter. The thing
about tweed is it's there for places where there's
no central heating. And these Oxford colleges,
their buildings often date back to before
the Reformation. It wasn't as if England
was famous for its central heating, even in
the 20th century. And so to understand the
tweed suit as a phenomenon, you have to
remember these studies are pretty cold,
even if you've got a fire in the grate. Now that
we are heading towards another energy crisis,
I believe the tweed suit will recover, maybe not
in the United States, but in England. Pretty soon
there's going to be a run on tweed suits.
Tim Ferriss: You heard it here first,
folks. Alpha, Niall Ferguson is long tweed.
Niall Ferguson: Long tweed.
Tim Ferriss: So a few just
miscellanea. Mordechai, incredible name. Always
one of my favorites. You mentioned Percivale. That
may not have been the P of the A.J.P., but also
a fantastic name. Could you say a bit more about
the role of contingency, I guess the throughline,
one of the throughlines, of Taylor's writing? And
you can answer these out of order, of course.
For someone who wanted to get a good taste
of his writing because your description of
paradox and the use of paradox and powerful
metaphor and prose is really appealing to
me. Where would you suggest someone start
or where would you suggest perhaps I start?
Niall Ferguson: Well, I'll give you a couple
of examples of historical contingency.
First, the decision for war in 1914
was taken in Britain on a weekend, which was an
unusual time for the British cabinet to meet.
And when they went into the meeting, I think
it's fair to say that nobody really knew
how it would turn out. In particular, the then
Chancellor of the Exchequer, David Lloyd George,
was expected to be against intervention
because he had been a man of the left,
and it was not obvious that intervening in the
war was a particularly left liberal thing to do.
There were plenty of people in the cabinet who had
deep reservations about intervening in the war,
and it was seen as something that the
conservators were much more enthusiastic
for. And so people expected Lloyd George to
speak up against intervention. He'd already
given indications prior to August second that
he had doubts about the wisdom of action.
But he didn't. Even although he was handed a note
by one of his cabinet colleagues encouraging him
to speak up, he had decided that it would
ultimately be better for David Lloyd George
if Britain went to war. And he was right because
he ended up becoming Prime Minister during the
war because Herbert Asquith had descended
into a kind of alcoholic fog. That's a good
example of how one individual's action or lack
of action can have very profound consequences.
And I wrote a lot about that in The Pity Of
War and in the book Virtual History because
I think it's important for people to understand
that while there are great historical forces at
work, there were powerful forces driving Europe
towards conflict prior to 1914, there is a
very important role for contingency, and that
continues to be true today. And once you think
about the historical process — and in a similar
way, let me give you a contemporary example.
Tim Ferriss: May I pause just for one sec? So in
terms of contingency, just the use of that word,
I think of contingency in the context
of say contingency plan. In this case,
do you mean it's a split test with an
alternate version of historical reality
where someone did or did not do something, did
or did not play a part in a given conversation?
Is that what you mean by contingency?
Niall Ferguson: Contingency here means
a relatively small event or decision.
And it doesn't need to be a decision.
It can be something accidental, has very major
consequences. And historical causations like that,
something relatively small, can have tremendous
ramifications. I'll give you another illustration.
This year, most people, including the US
government, thought that if Russia invaded
Ukraine, the Ukrainian government would quite
quickly fold, and it was assumed that Volodymyr
Zelenskyy, the Ukrainian president, would bail. He
didn't. He gave his famous response, "I don't want
an air ticket. I want ammunition." And Zelenskyy's
courage when they were closing in on Kyiv with a
high probability that they would assassinate,
the Russians turned the course of history in a
way that I think is now quite widely understood.
People know Zelenskyy is an important historical
figure. He gets a lot of attention because he is
a charismatic figure who understands how to use
modern media to communicate with an audience.
That's the benefit of having a very seasoned
entertainer as your president. But I think what's
really important there is that his courage,
particularly the famous video selfie video where
he says, "I'm here. The defense minister is here.
We're here." They're standing in the streets of
Kyiv. The Russians are closing in at that point on
the capital. That was a tremendous act of courage.
But it emboldened ordinary Ukrainians not to fold,
and it also intimidated the collaborators who
were ready to help the Russians, not to act.
So the contingency there is if Zelenskyy had gone
according to our expectation and taken the plane,
then Putin would've had Kyiv within a matter
of days or weeks, and the war would be over.
So I think one of the things that's exciting about
the study of history is you are trying to remind
yourself again and again that what happened,
that what we know happened, might have gone
the other way. That the Cuban Missile Crisis
ended in both sides essentially backing down
was not predetermined. There was a moment when a
Soviet submarine commander gave the order to fire
a nuclear torpedo at US naval surface ships. So
we came within a hair's breadth of World War III.
These alternate worlds, these histories
that didn't happen, have to be alive
in your mind when you are writing history.
The fatal mistake is to write history as if
it was bound to happen the way it happened.
And this, of course, is the mistake that a
great majority of historians make. Forgetting
that, we don't know at the time, at the moment,
we didn't know the morning of the 24th of February
that Zelenskyy would stand his ground. Nobody
knew that. I wonder if even Zelenskyy at that
moment knew what it was that he was going to do.
So I say all this because I think it's really
important to convey to your listeners and viewers
how exciting history is and how studying it makes
you understand the course of events in your own
life better removes that passivity that sometimes
people succumb to. If you think great historical
forces are going to have inevitable outcomes, if
you have a deterministic view of the historical
process, it's very easy to lapse into fatalism.
There's the other trap, which is the conspiracy
theories. "Well, the truth of the matter is
that actually, Soros and the Rothschilds are
orchestrating all this." Again, you throw
up your hands and you abandon the attempt
to understand how the historical process works.
Okay. What should one read to get a flavor of Alan
Taylor's extraordinary talent? He developed —
Tim Ferriss: You have a very good short-term
memory, by the way. You have
a very good short-term memory.
Niall Ferguson: I do my best.
Tim Ferriss: Please continue.
Niall Ferguson: Taylor's masterpiece is quite
a dense read, and I wouldn't recommend it,
The Struggle for Mastery in Europe. That's the
book I most admire, but it's probably the last
thing to start with. It's —
Tim Ferriss: The widowmaker.
Niall Ferguson: Yeah. I mean, I love the book,
but I'm a little idiosyncratic. I like long and
dense books. But the essays that he wrote,
which were often book reviews, are available
in paperback collections. In the old days, they
used to publish the essays of historians. I wish
they still did because I would've many more books
to my credit if I could just repackage my essays
as books. But his books of essays are really
worth reading. In the same way that if you want
to get to Orwell, don't just read Animal Farm
and 1984. Read Orwell's amazing essays. There
are four fantastic volumes of Orwell's essays.
And he and Taylor between them were just such
masters of short form English prose. You will
just feel like you are eating Turkish delight
as you read your way through their essays.
Tim Ferriss: Just in the vein of adding to
your tally of books published, if the
book doesn't exist with the title,
The Histories that Didn't Happen, just saying,
has a nice ring to it, a bit of alliteration, easy
to grasp, not too abstract. In any case, I just —
Niall Ferguson: Lewis Namier was a great Cambridge
historian who said that the key to history was
having a sense of what didn't happen. And I always
think of Thelonious Monk's line about jazz. "It's
the notes you don't play." And as a jazz fan, I
think history has to have that kind of Thelonious
Monk feel to it where you're telling the reader,
"This didn't happen, but it nearly did, and people
at the time thought about it." This is the key
rule, by the way. You can't just fantasize and
devise counterfactuals that are entirely out of
your imagination. You have to go with things that
people at the time thought might happen. That's
a really important guardrail on counterfactual
history. The fancy term for what-if history or
histories that didn't happen is counterfactual
history. And I'm a passionate believer in it.
And I'm proud to say that despite my making the
argument for counterfactual history back in the
1990s, that's a long time ago now, it's still
counterculture. It's still what the cool kids
do in history, and the establishment still looks
down on it. I used to be annoyed about that. I
used to think, "Why don't they understand? Why
do these people not see you have to talk about
what didn't happen?" And now I'm glad that it's
still cool and minority and underground. That's
fine with me. You established historians carry
on doing what you are doing. You carry on saying,
"We are only here to study what did happen." You
carry on doing that. But just know that the cool
kids have seen through this and they know that
it's really BS. You have to talk about what didn't
happen to understand what did happen, obviously.
Tim Ferriss: Or all the things that so nearly
didn't happen. And I'm no historian. I make
no claims otherwise. Don't play one on the
internet. However, I did listen. Don't know how
you feel about this podcast, but I have enjoyed
many episodes of Hardcore History by Dan Carlin,
who would not call himself a historian either,
but he did an episode on the assassination
of Franz Ferdinand and everything that came
of that. And when you dig into the specifics, I
mean, it is just mind-boggling to think how that
came about and how many near-misses.
It just boggles the mind to think
how as you put, if you zoom too far out and just
view history as these inevitable tectonic plates,
then there's a fatalism that can set in and you
throw up your hands and move on to just staring
at TikTok all day or whatever you might do. And
at the same time, if you bleed into the conspiracy
theory side of things, same outcome. But I need
to do more reading. Part of what you describe —
Niall Ferguson: By the way, Dan Carlin is
great. Dan Carlin is great. I love what he
does. I haven't heard that particular episode, but
anything that gets a wider audience for history is
good. And I recently heard his great interview
with Elon Musk about the technology of World War
II. It's brilliant, and it's brilliant partly
because Elon knows a lot about the hardware of
World War II. And so you think of World War II,
it's an engineering problem in the end. It's like,
who can build better planes, better tanks, all
that stuff? But Carlin's doing terrific work.
And yeah, you're right. 1914 is a perfect
illustration because Princip, the assassin,
totally fails the first time. And how many
assassins get a second chance because the driver
of the target takes the wrong turning? That's —
Tim Ferriss: And then he stops right next to the
bar where you're getting hammered because you
failed your first attempt or whatever the story
is. It's crazy. Are there any other examples
of correspondence that you have been taken by,
not necessarily in the same way, but in a similar
way to the exchanges between the Rothschilds?
And the reason I ask is I consume a lot of
biographies, I do read a fair amount of history,
but I don't really know how to assess
historians. And I wish I had a way of
establishing the biases up front because we're
all humans, subjective. There must be biases,
I'd imagine. So much like a conflict of interest
or special interest section in a scientific paper
like, "Okay. At least we know what chips these
people have on the board." So I have defaulted
to looking for correspondence that was never
intended for publication as a way to get a view
into the thinking of the time, what was happening
at the time. Are there any other examples that
pop up when I use the prompt correspondence?
Niall Ferguson: Absolutely. Part of what's
attractive about historical study is reading
the letters and diaries of the dead or very,
very old and the non-published material.
If you inhabit the world of the published,
which many historians do, that is to say, they
essentially write their books on the basis of
things that have been published, whether it's
books or articles, you are really doing research
at one remove from reality. I've written books
like that, and there is a role for them because
you are really synthesizing the scholarship of
many, many authors and trying to produce a single
distilled version of what happened.
But there's a difference between
writing a book based on published material and
writing a book based on unpublished material,
and it's a huge difference. I attach much more
importance to books that I've written based on
unpublished material and books that others have
written. Why? Because that which is published
is essentially filtered. A huge filter has
determined what sees the light of day in print.
When you enter an archive, the only
filter is that nobody destroyed it
and somebody thought to preserve it in
at least enough of an orderly form that
you can look at it. And this is a radically
different world that you enter. It's not a
perfect representation of reality, but it's a lot
closer to reality than the published material.
And so let me illustrate the point. As I
write the biography of Henry Kissinger,
the first volume of which came out a few
years ago, I'm writing the second volume now,
there is, of course, a very well-established
narrative about the Vietnam War, about the
Cold War, about the opening to China, about the
Middle East. It's all very well established. There
are lots of books out there about it. But when you
enter the realm of the unpublished correspondence,
including transcripts of telephone calls, even the
tapes of telephone calls, which were certainly not
supposed to see the light of day because the
Nixon administration's the best documented
administration of all time thanks to Nixon's
ultimately fatal error of taping everything,
the world is a very different one
from that world that you thought
you understood, thanks to Christopher Hitchens.
I mean, Christopher Hitchens' book on Kissinger
has sold many copies. It contains, I think from
memory, 12 footnotes. It refers to that many
sources. It is a work of journalism of outrageous
superficiality. It's a polemical hatchet job,
and it shouldn't be treated as history. Hitch was
a friend of mine. I miss him. But it's important
to recognize that that's not a work of history,
really. Another way of thinking about this is
what's the ratio of words read to words written?
Now I wish, Tim, that that ratio was published on
the front of books. So this is a one-to-one
book. He read basically one word for every
word that he wrote. And this is a 100-to-1 book.
And this is a 1,000-to-1 book. And 1,000-to-1,
it seems like it's about right. I mean, most
books are really not worth reading because
their ratio is close to unity. There may even be
books where the ratio's below unity, that they've
written actually more words than they've read in
preparing to write the book. The best history —
Tim Ferriss: Sounds like the
internet in a nutshell. Yeah.
Niall Ferguson: I mean, that's the blogosphere.
It's like, "Why bother doing research? I have a
great opinion." So I'm a very much 1,000-to-1 kind
of person. I like to dig deeply and broadly and
to enter that realm of the unpublished. And I'm
insatiable as I enter it. I can never be entirely
satisfied. I'm reconstructing Kissinger's life
almost on an hour-by-hour basis to try to see
a new way of thinking about the 1970s, which
was a pivotal decade in a great many ways. To
rethink that decade is my current mission. And
of course, I won't succeed in changing that many
people's minds because most people made up their
minds about Henry Kissinger long ago in about,
I don't know, 1974. But I do think we have to
rethink the Cold War as a matter of urgency
because we're in one. We're in a new cold war,
in Cold War II. And if we don't think long and
hard about what went right and what went wrong in
Cold War I, there is a high probability that we
are going to repeat some pretty serious mistakes.
Tim Ferriss: Let's talk about Cold War II. I was
actually going to segue to your thinking and
observations of the not mutually exclusive
combination of maybe conditions that have been
set over the last five to 10 or more years that
are now leading to certain types of inertia
in terms of trends, converging trends that may
or may not be avoidable. Then there's a lot of
wiggle room with independent actors and so on,
as we've discussed. But I've already described
Cold War II, I believe, correct me if I'm wrong,
as China, senior partner, Russia, junior
partner, in contrast to Cold War I. If you were
placing bets on likely events or
developments over the next handful of years,
what would you put out as perhaps some reasonably
probable scenarios that we'll see develop?
Niall Ferguson: Great question. The cliche
quote often ascribed to Mark Twain is that
history doesn't repeat itself, but
it rhymes. But he never said that.
Twain never used those words. That's a
made-up quote. What Twain actually said
back in the 1870s was that that history was a
bit like a kaleidoscope. And as you turned it,
certain patterns could repeat themselves.
So let's think about this as a kaleidoscope.
You'll remember those things we had as
kids where you stick it to your eyes —
Tim Ferriss: Oh, yes.
Niall Ferguson: —and it’s like, "That's
psychedelic. What happens if I turn? Oh.
That's also psychedelic, but different."
Cold War I had certain common features with Cold
War II, and there were certain very important
differences. So we shouldn't expect things to
play out exactly the same. On the other hand, it's
clear that we have an ideological rivalry between
the United States and the People's Republic of
China. There is clearly a technological race going
on. There is also a geopolitical dimension to this
conventional territorial dimension. And this is
a point Graham Allison made in his book, Destined
for War. There are some probability that they end
up in a hot war because what's a cold war? George
Orwell coined the phrase to mean a peace that
is no peace. It is something that has latent,
the possibility of an actual hot war. And I think
the United States and China have been in this kind
of cold war situation for at least four years,
maybe longer. I think the Chinese would probably
say longer, but we didn't notice. We didn't
notice the beginning of Cold War I either.
When Orwell talks about Cold War in 1945 and
Churchill in 1946 talked about an iron curtain,
most Americans were, "No. Stalin's
been our ally in World War II.
You are just warmongering." And it took until
1950 when there was a hot war in Korea for most
Americans to say, "Maybe they're right." I mean,
Kennan wasn't immediately hailed as a prophet
when he talks about containment. The thing about
cold wars is that by and large, people in the West
don't really notice their beginning, and take a
while to understand the scale of the challenge.
So we're at that early cold war stage. I think
that's a good analogy. That works well. And also,
this war in Ukraine is like the Korean
War. It's the first hot war of Cold War II,
and it makes you get that you are in a cold
war. As in Cold War I, the hot war happens
in a slightly unexpected location. The hot
war that kicked off Cold War I was Korea,
and the US hadn't really been paying very
close attention to Korea when that kicked off.
So if you take this kind of approach and
recognize that there are similarities,
except that instead of a nuclear arms race,
we're in an AI race and a quantum computing race,
if you recognize the difference, which is
there's much more economic interpenetration
between the US and China than the ever
was between the US and the Soviet Union,
you are then in a position to start
hazarding guesses about what happens next,
which is what you asked me to do. And these are
very difficult things to get right. And I often
think that if one makes a right prediction,
it's more luck that it turns out to be right
than judgment because this is a complex system
of enormous complexity. So when we try to say
anything about global politics, we're really
engaged in an exercise beyond our human brains.
But let me have a go. Right now, the US and China
are on a collision course over Taiwan. And Taiwan
is to this cold war what Cuba was to the last cold
war. It's the flash point. It's an island in close
proximity to one of the players. Then, it was
close to the US. This time, it's close to China.
It's an island which seems to be worth more than
its territorial size would suggest. Actually,
Taiwan's more important than Cuba ever
was because Taiwan is where 92 percent
of the most sophisticated semiconductors
in the world are manufactured by TSMC.
And so in some ways, the potential for a crisis
over Taiwan is higher than the potential ever was
for a crisis over Cuba. So I think what happens
next is that we end up with a showdown over Taiwan
at some point in the next few years. Could be in
2024 when there's an election scheduled in Taiwan.
And it would also make sense to do it
then from a Chinese point of view because
who knows who'll be president in 2025?
But probably not somebody as completely
incompetent as Joe Biden. So my sense is that the
crisis is not far away even although the Chinese
don't look terribly ready for full-blown invasion.
And that's the thing that I'll be watching most
closely in the coming years. The other thing to
remember is, and this again is in the nature of a
guess, that a characteristic feature of Cold War I
was the crises would happen in multiple locations
at roughly the same time. So the Middle East
always mattered, and it was the place where things
would periodically blow up. I think the Middle
East is about to blow up again because the Iranian
regime clearly has an incentive to get into a
war because when it's at war, it can slaughter
domestic opposition with much greater ease.
So I'm afraid that we are probably going to
see a Middle Eastern crisis even before Taiwan
blows up. And what worries me the most, Tim,
is that the lesson of Cold War I is that we only
narrowly avoided World War III, as I said already.
So if we're in this kind of a scenario where
there are crises in Eastern Europe, potentially
in the Middle East, potentially in the Far East, I
think just keeping this a cold war will be quite a
challenge. That will be a good outcome if it ends
the same way as Cold War I with peaceful victory
for the West. But there is no guarantee at this
point that Cold War II stays cold and there is no
guarantee at this point that the United States and
its allies win. And that's the real lesson of Cold
War I. It was not inevitable that it stayed
cold and it was not inevitable that we won.
Tim Ferriss: To follow up on a few things
that you mentioned, and as background,
I was an East Asian studies major at Princeton,
spent part of '96, about six months studying at
two universities in Beijing, so I was able to
see the bicycles Beijing prior to the Audi and
BMW Beijing that we see today. But the reason
I mentioned that is that I then subsequently
traveled quite a lot in South America and a
fair amount in Africa. And I was able to see
quite obviously the extensive
infrastructure that was being built
by Chinese companies also seemingly
often with Chinese governmental support.
And from a geopolitical natural resource
and resource distribution perspective,
this is not my area of expertise, but it seems
like China has been playing three-dimensional
chess for a while now with respect to
all of that. As you mentioned, Taiwan is
strategically from a technological manufacturing
perspective, non-trivial compared to, say, Cuba.
And my question is what can the US do? Or
is it a day late and a dollar short? I don't
want to make it too fatalistic, but for the
US to be prepared or prepare itself and not
just be pseudo prepared, which we have been
for many things in the last several years,
what can be done? What would you suggest?
Niall Ferguson: Well, you are right to point
out that this is a global challenge that China's
focused not only on Taiwan or for that matter, the
South China Sea on its own neighborhood. It has
been pursuing an ambitious and quite heterogeneous
global strategy since Xi Jinping came to par. And
the Belt and Road initiative is only part of that.
There are all kinds of other things, Digital Silk
Road, the export of surveillance technology to
governments in the developing world, investment in
lots of technology companies in emerging markets.
You can see the infrastructure when you go
to Africa. Even 10 years ago when I made a
documentary about this for British television, a
place like Zambia had really quite extraordinary
and visible Chinese presence, not only in
football stadiums and highways, but also in
mining and agriculture. There's no
question that we confront a new kind
of Chinese challenge because there really
hasn't been an era until now when China
was so clearly pursuing a global strategy.
And by the way, that strategy was copied from
the West. There was a conscious decision by
Chinese leaders to learn from Western history
and to try and adopt some of the things that
we had done that Chinese empires hadn't done,
really hadn't even contemplated doing
since all the way back in the 15th century.
This hybrid China, which simultaneously has
continuities from Chinese imperial history,
from the Mao era, is also a China doing
things that China hasn't done in the past.
I think the United States has adopted recently
a strategy of technological containment
that's most obvious in the recent restrictions
imposed by the Commerce Department that are
designed to prevent China advancing
technologically by denying it access
to the most sophisticated semiconductors
and the equipment you need to make them.
Our strategy is to try to freeze China's
technological advance and we'll see how that goes.
Tim Ferriss: Seems hard to do. Seems hard to do.
Niall Ferguson: Right. On the one side,
it's extremely hard to build TSMC in mainland
China, and I think there is some reason to
believe they can't. But the idea that you
can just use economic sanctions to keep
your principal adversary permanently behind you
technologically to me historically seems like
a stretch and would seem also to me to raise the
incentives for Xi Jinping to take Taiwan. Because
if he can't access the TSMC products, then he
can either try and get control of TSMC. But if he
fails and we blow it up or they blow it up, then
he's no worse off. But we are a lot worse off. I
think there are downside risks to our strategy of
technological containment that aren't being given
enough attention. Broadly speaking, I think a
regime like China's is at its most dangerous
when it starts to feel that its strategic options
are narrowing and that there may in fact be only
a small window of opportunity to bid for primacy
or at least parity with the dominant superpower.
We could do an awful lot more creative things
than we are doing in developing countries.
That is to say we could compete much better in
Africa. But the problem is when we go to Africa,
we come bearing aid, it usually has lots of
strings attached to it. When the Chinese show up,
there are not many strings and it's not aid,
it's investment, to put it very simply. We're
not really offering a particularly attractive
alternative. A concrete example of this is when
we decided that it would be a bad idea for
Huawei to supply the world's 5G networks. We
went around telling everybody Huawei very bad,
but we didn't have a better alternative. As
one of my African friends complains that "You'd
come and tell us not to buy Huawei. We listen,
and then we say, 'So what should we buy?'
And it's like, 'Oh, we don't know.'"
Or try Ericcson. It's way more expensive
and they won't give you any credit,
but try — that's stupid. We can't expect to win
Cold War II if we have no better product. At
least when the Soviets were going around Africa
saying, "We'll give you the planned economy,"
we had a better idea. We definitely had a better
pitch than the planned economy. I think that's
what concerns me is that our strategy in Cold War
II at this point looks very risky and quite likely
to fail. And that's because when you read the
most recent national security strategy document,
we write things like, "We don't want to
have a cold war. This is not a cold war."
And then we go right ahead and list
all the things that we're doing that
makes it very clear that we are in a cold war.
Tim Ferriss: That's the news that I see every day
now, which is “so and so says we may be entering
a recession in six to 12 months.” I'm like,
am I seeing a different version of reality here?
Niall Ferguson: Yeah, I know.
Tim Ferriss: Thou doth protest too much.
Niall Ferguson: The cognitive dissonance is
painful to manage whether you're talking about
the economy or about our foreign policy. Yeah,
that's what I'm thinking a lot about
and I do it tentatively because
things could change direction in an unexpected
way. American politics is always a bit of a
wild card, but it's pretty clear that
the pendulum is swinging to the right.
That means that there's a pretty high
probability of a Republican president
by January 2025. And who knows? If Donald Trump
is reelected, he could call off Cold War II in
an afternoon. He could fly to Beijing and do
the best deal. "Such a great deal with my good
friend Xi Jinping." That could happen. And most
people struggle a little bit with that part of
thinking about history because we like —
Tim Ferriss: Could you say a bit more
about that? Why would it be so easy?
Niall Ferguson: That's what he would've
done if he'd been reelected. Trump doesn't want to
be in Cold War II. He thinks it's stupid. He just
wanted to do trade war. And what's funny about
the Trump administration was that Trump turns
everybody's attention to China, wins the argument,
convinces everybody China's a major threat, but
all he really wanted to do was a trade war with
tariffs. And the point of the tariffs was to beat
China up and then he was going to go to Beijing
and do a great deal. That was the plan. That was
going to be a photo op. And of course he didn't
win. And so that didn't happen. And ironically,
the Biden administration has been more hawkish
on China than the Trump administration was. And
that's also a product of American politics because
at some point in 2020, Biden's handlers said to
him, "You can't win unless you are as hawkish
on China as Trump and maybe more hawkish."
And so Biden, who'd in fact been anything but
hawkish during his time as vice president,
on the campaign trail started to beat up on China.
And then they got stuck with this hawkish policy,
which is now dominating their whole strategy. I
think it's important to recognize that Trump's
foreign policy, however you think about Trump,
however much you hate Trump, and many people
listening to this will have major reasons for
hating Trump, but the foreign policy objectivity
was quite successful and it was quite successful
without risking conflict. Trump was not somebody
who wanted actual war, he just wanted trade war.
And the trade war was always intended to be a
temporary measure. You were imposing the tariffs
and then you were going to go to China and say,
"Well, we'll take the tariffs off if you do this."
I can imagine a scenario where, quite easily can
imagine a scenario where Trump gets reelected and
does that. At that point, Cold War II would at
least temporarily be in some kind of suspension.
Tim Ferriss: I'd love for you to poke holes
in a bunch of things I'm going to say
because I wouldn't call them terribly
well informed. We'll start there. Ample fodder
for conversation. The first thought is that if
mainland China — well, first of all, I've just
been very impressed with the geopolitical,
both visible and invisible or less
visible strategies that have been
deployed by the People's Republic. It's
always seemed very much long-term investment
versus aid like you mentioned. And it seems to
me like if mainland China wanted to take Taiwan,
there are many things that would
suggest they could do it nonviolently.
There are other ways for them to isolate Taiwan
just as an island. There are probably multiple
ways they could cut off various types of
access. It's not as easy for allies to,
say, supply aid to Taiwan compared to
say Ukraine, where there's also imminent
neighbor threat that is perceived in Europe.
That's the first thought to me is that it doesn't
seem like it would actually be that hard if they
were to approach it and say, "Hey, look guys,
nobody wants a violent outcome here. You're
going to be on your own. Maybe the US steps in,
probably not. Your military, yes you have
mandatory service, but let's be real. You
don't get a whole lot of practice." I have
to imagine that to your point though, moving
quickly could be to their benefit. And secondly,
and again, then you can rip all of this to shreds.
Second is more an observation that perhaps even
if we are totally inept, we are still saved
in the sense that China and the US are so
economically entangled that China could end up
being the rider on the horse and the horse is the
US but they can't shoot their horse in the head.
They still need the horse, whether that is
a byproduct of a lot of reserve currency in
the form of treasuries or US dollars or
whatever, or trying to sustain exports
so their domestic economy doesn't face all
sorts of issues. The question then I guess is
do you see either of those holding any water or
do you think to take Taiwan it would escalate,
putting aside the Trump intervention,
to a physical hot war type of conflict?
Niall Ferguson: The challenge for Beijing
is that the softy, softy approach,
which was essentially to use economics and
information warfare to bring Taiwan closer to
the PRC has failed. And it was obviously failing
back in 2020 when all Chinese efforts to influence
the Taiwanese election came to nothing. And
if one looks at the sentiment of the Taiwanese
population, it has gone not in the direction
of full independence, but it leans towards,
we like the status quo and we'd ultimately
independence one day. The direction of travel
from the vantage point of Beijing is very
uncongenial. That's the first point. The
second point is that there are things that
you can do short of an amphibious landing,
blockade being the obvious one. And
they showed us that they could do that,
but a blockade's an act of war. Even if
you haven't landed the troops on the beach,
you're still using coercion to assert control over
Taiwan. And this is where US policies is crucial.
The US has had for half a century, more or less,
a policy of strategic ambiguity where it's not
quite clear what we would do in such a scenario.
We acknowledged, this was one of Kissinger's
achievements, the One China principle. We
don't treat Taiwan as an independent country
formally. On the other hand, we reserve the right
under 1979 legislation to prevent any violent
change in Taiwan's current status. The problem
is we really moved away from that ambiguity in
the last couple of years. It began I think with
discussion in foreign policy circles of strategic
ambiguity. Do we really need it? Richard Haass
wrote a piece about that for Foreign Affairs,
but now Biden himself on three, is it four
occasions, has talked as if there's no ambiguity.
We will definitely defend Taiwan. And although
those statements have been walked back, we've
succeeded in signaling to the Chinese that we are
no longer committed to strategic ambiguity. And
we also keep talking about practical ways
in which we will make Taiwan a porcupine,
as able to defend itself as we made Ukraine.
We also, in addition to that, treat Taiwan de
facto as an independent country when someone
like Nancy Pelosi goes there and every single
aspect of her behavior is that which you
would expect the speaker of the House of
Representatives to engage in in an independent
country. I think from Beijing's point of view,
we have shifted our position on Taiwan in a way
that is profoundly troubling to them because Xi
Jinping's number one priority, the reason he
extended his time in office, let me be clear
about that, the number one reason he did that was
to take Taiwan under the control of the Chinese
Communist Party. If we are saying actually, "No
ambiguity, Taiwan is an independent country and
we'll defend it," that is a major problem for Xi
Jinping. I think that's why even a blockade would
force the United States to take action. I
don't think there's a scenario in which this
administration would sit back and say, "Oh, well.
Never mind. That's just the One China policy."
Now my short term memory is failing me
because the second question you asked was —
Tim Ferriss: There were two more or less,
let's see, there were two elements. The
second element was the mutual life situation.
Niall Ferguson: Oh absolutely. Clearly this is
something very different about Cold War II. The
economic ties between the United States and the
Soviet Union were minimal and trivial, whereas
Chimerica still exists. Now this was one of my
favorite Niall-ogisms. Back in 2007, I came up
with Chimerica to explain the neo fusion of the
Chinese and American economies, but I also used
that word to make a pun on the word "chimera."
The argument in 2007 was "This isn't sustainable,
folks." And sure enough it hasn't been. I think
there are still many people in the US who can't
get past the extent of US investment in China,
Chinese investment in the US, the trade deficit
is still enormous. We buy a lot of Chinese stuff
and they say, "And therefore we can't possibly
have a conflict." Sometimes this takes the
form of "There won't be a war over Taiwan because
both sides would be so economically hurt by that"
And I call this the theory of mutually assured
financial destruction. The problem with all of
this is, to switch analogies, you could have
said all of these sorts of thing about the
United Kingdom and Germany on the eve of 1914. And
indeed somebody did. Norman Angell wrote a whole
book called The Great Illusion saying there's
no possibility that they have a war. It would
just be so financially ruinous. Well, actually
it's true that the UK and Germany were very,
very interdependent economically in the early
1900s, but they stopped being economically
interdependent in a matter of days when war
broke out. Decoupling happened so fast that
it's amazing to look back on it, that the Royal
Navy literally cut the submarine telegraph cables
from Germany to the rest of the world within
days of the outbreak of war. And legislation
was introduced that effectively expropriated
German nationals' holdings of British assets.
The US did the same when it joined the war
in 1917. I keep warning people that economic
interdependence does not preclude conflict. And
you will be amazed how fast the decoupling happens
when the conflict begins. And if you don't
believe me, let me introduce you to Russia
because what happened to Russia after February the
24th was unbelievably rapid decoupling from the
western economy, not the world economy. They're
still able to trade with China and India, but
they really got switched off very aggressively by
sanctions imposed immediately after the outbreak
of war. I think it's clear that our playbook is
very sanctions-reliant and the Chinese know this
and so they know that in the event of conflict
they will face aggressive American sanctions.
And I dare say, going back to your point about
their ability to plan, that they're hard at work.
In fact, I know they're hard at work right now
to try and sanctions-proof themselves and also
to make sure that any measures like that blow
back on the US and cause significant harm to
US economic interests too. I don't rely at all on
the economic interdependence. I don't think that's
any way an obstacle to conflict. It just makes
the conflict really expensive. But hey, World
War I was really expensive. Didn't not happen.
Tim Ferriss: Is there anything then, going from
observer and a student of history to spotter of
patterns, is there anything that you are doing
right now or would like to do as an agent
of change to try to steer things in any
direction or another? Doesn't have
to be specific to China. It could be.
Niall Ferguson: Yeah, I would be strange if I
just sat in my study at the Hoover Institution
having conversations like this and then going
and playing tennis. Part of what has been
central to my life in the last decade has been
trying to apply history to contemporary problems
and then do something about it. That means mostly
advice. I'm not probably that well suited to
political office. I don't have any aspirations
to be Henry Kissinger, i.e., go from being a
professor to being national security advisor.
That's not really a plausible trajectory for me.
But I think that in advising people in decision
making positions, I can achieve something.
There are a couple of aspects to this. One is
that about 10 years ago I created something
called Greenmantle, which I think you mentioned in
your nice introduction. Greenmantle is an advisory
business that works with a relatively small number
of mostly financial clients just to understand
the world using the application of history.
And it's been a way for me to do work that
is off the radar, not in the public
domain, that therefore isn't subject
to the incentives that exist in the
public domain. When you do journalism,
you can't be boring. You have an obligation not
only to inform but to, at some level, entertain.
And therefore, the minute you enter the
public domain, you are going to make things
more interesting than they may actually
be. Whereas if I'm working at Greenmantle,
I just have to be right. And often
the right answer is quite boring
and boring but important is what I like. I'm
happily engaged in helping people who manage
fairly large asset pools think about how the world
is going. And I can afford to be very boring and
nerdy when I do that. I can be quite boring on
the subject of semiconductors or I can be quite
boring on the subject of the US treasury market
or monetary policy or whether the Chinese have the
naval capacity to do an amphibious landing.
I spend a lot of my time
relishing the nuts and bolts, the granular
analysis that makes pattern recognition serious.
Punditry on cable TV is the opposite of that.
And although I'll sometimes go on cable TV,
not least to sell my books, I hope I never engage
in the kind of punditry that is just designed to
get me retweets and social media followers.
You can always predict the end of the world
and get attention. My book Doom makes fun of the
pattern where the incentives to predict the end of
the world are very strong, and World War III and
the next financial crisis. You can predict that
every year and have an audience no matter how many
times you're wrong because people will always pay
to be told the end of the world is nigh. I'm not
interested in that. I'm interested in doing the
kind of pattern recognition that gets it right.
Which I think, for example, Greenmantle did. In
January 2020, we told clients "There is a
global pandemic coming. It is going to be
hugely disruptive." And we got that right in
January, right at the beginning. Beginning
of 2021, "There's going to be an inflation mess.
They've really screwed this up." Beginning of this
year, "Russia is going to invade Ukraine with 80
percent probability." That's part of what I do and
I find it very intellectually rigorous because
unlike in academia, when you are wrong, there are
consequences and being wrong will get you fired
on Wall Street. That's very good for focusing
the mind. Second thing I do is talk to the people
who make policy or in the future may make policy.
And I'm always willing to go to Washington, or
for that matter, to London and share my thoughts
with the people who have the very arduous
task of taking decisions under pressure
and under uncertainty with very little time.
I am privileged. I get paid to think and read.
Nobody in government has time to do either of
those things. You're just in meeting after meeting
and call after call. As Kissinger said, you draw
down your intellectual capital in government
because you don't have time to accumulate any.
I'm always happy to put myself at the service
of the people who have the difficult tasks. I'm
bipartisan about that. I would be as ready to
talk to Jake Sullivan as I was to talk to H.R.
McMaster. It's just that Jake never calls me up,
but I'm here. And that's what I'm more than happy
to do with all humility because one thing's for
sure, the people in the situation room know
things that we don't know. They just know a
lot of things we don't know. And if you are in the
position of being an academic who pontificates,
you should always be quite humble because
there's just no way that you know the half of it.
Yeah, that's my approach. I think
it's something I got better at. I
can certainly look back to the early days when I
was trying to be involved in policy discussions
shortly after moving to the US and I was pretty
amateurish then. I think the analytical framework
of the book Colossus was correct, namely the
neo conservative project to build empires in
Iraq and Afghanistan will fail. And my criticisms
of the neo-conservative project were pretty much
right. But I don't think I went about that
in a very intelligent way. I was too new.
Tim Ferriss: What has changed? How has
the toolkit developed or the framework,
how has that changed over time? What has made
you more professional and less amateur in how
you approach these discussions?
Niall Ferguson: Doing it with a
team rather than being the solo tweed-clad
superhero. Ultimately, these things are too
complicated and difficult for any one person to
be able to fit it all together and know enough.
When Greenmantle came into existence, my policy
was to hire my smartest students to come and
work with me to think about this and see if
applying history could even work. And then
crucially having taken them on to encourage them
to disagree with me and tell me that I'm wrong.
And now most of what I will say on these subjects,
as in our discussion, is informed by a lot of work
that other younger, smarter people do. I'll give
you an example. Back when the idea of Cold War II
first hit me, it hit me because Greenmantle
was doing some work on Huawei and there was
a map of the world which showed countries that
were using Huawei technology, countries that had
essentially refused to use it, and the countries
that hadn't made up their minds. And I remember
thinking when I saw the map, "Ah, it's a cold war
map. That's a recognizable cold war map, one side,
two sides non-aligned." And so I got excited and
started to think about this and I said, "Hey, we
really need to work on that issue and that issue,
and what are we doing about challenges to the
dollar? What are we doing about semiconductors?"
And out of that, those discussions came some
really good work by other people.
Chris Miller's new book, Chip War,
which I highly recommend, is just the best
book on why semiconductors really matter.
And Eyck Freymann has done some excellent work on
climate aspects of Cold War II because climate's a
cold war issue given that China's responsible for
a huge proportion of the increase in CO2 emissions
over the last 20 years. So I'm glad to say that I
no longer fly solo. I work in a team. I've learned
a lot from good leaders of teams how to build a
network that is greater than the sum of its parts.
And I think that's why the quality of analysis
is better than it was pre-Greenmantle when I
was inclined to try and do everything myself. And
that way you make mistakes. I made some terrible
mistakes pre-Greenmantle. I got interest rates
really wrong in 2010 and Paul Krugman was able
to jump up and down on me with hobnail boots
on because he was right and I was wrong and
I learned a valuable lesson then, if you're
going to go out there and do battle with Nobel
laureates, you better have done your homework.
Tim Ferriss: So I'm going to take a left turn
here. So we've been talking about a lot of macro
issues, but a lot of current geopolitical issues.
I want to ask you about fatherhood. So I have
a note here that fatherhood has been the best
thing you've ever done. And as someone who does
not yet have children but someday hopes to,
could you please expand on that? I'd
love to hear why that is the case.
Niall Ferguson: Well I only have five children.
Tim Ferriss: You've got some work to do to
catch up with Elon, but you're doing all right.
Niall Ferguson: There are others who've beaten me
and I won't catch up. I'm too old to have any more
children because in the end you can have children
at 58 but you will not be good at soccer
when they are ready for soccer and you
have a moral obligation to be able
to go and kick that ball around.
I have children who range in age from 28 down
to five and I can say unequivocally that they
are the best thing that ever happened to me and
the thing I care, the people I care most about,
and I never tire of watching them
grow, helping them in any way I can.
Fatherhood for me has been more fulfilling than
I would ever have imagined. I think most people,
most men, let me say, most men before they become
fathers, secretly dread the loss of freedom,
the regime of diapers and the
prospect of being vomited on.
And all of these things will happen when
you become a father. You will be vomited on,
diapers will become a very large, and unpleasant
part of your life and you won't be able to go
out anything like you were able to before.
On the other hand, there is something far
more fulfilling about helping an infant learn
than anything else that's available to us. So
I don't know that I've been at all a great father,
I think I've been okay. And the way I would think
about the role is it's very much pedagogical.
I very assiduously read to my children and
get them to read and make books a big part of
life. I think that's really critical because
these days as children grow up, there are way more
distractions than there were in my day and you
have to make a concentrated effort as a parent to
make sure that they get into the habit of reading
books because almost all the accumulated wisdom
of our species is in fact contained in books.
And some of these books are quite old and
unlikely to be assigned in contemporary education,
so that's a big part of it. Then there's all the
kind of that funny business of teaching children
to be good. What is it to be good? What is it
to be kind? How does one actually convey that?
How can one make a child creative without
over scheduling them with Monday's piano,
Tuesday's coding, Wednesday's Mandarin,
that kind of typical parenting. And I'm
still learning. I'm still trying to get
better at it while at the same time,
making sure that all the children got the same
kind of deal because I'm quite egalitarian about
these things and there can be no favoritism.
They all must think they're the favorite.
So these are the things that if you gave
me the chance, I would talk about with
greater enthusiasm and at greater length than
then about anything else. But nobody really
wants to listen to somebody else talk about their
children, it's the world's most boring subject,
just like when people get out their phones
to show you pictures of their children and
then they can't find them because they have too
many pictures. A little part of you dies, right?
Tim Ferriss: Well to me at the moment, this
is interesting. So since I have the mic in
front of me, I'll keep prying when you said
"I'm okay," and I might be getting the exact
phrasing wrong, "not great." Why do you say that?
Niall Ferguson: Absence. Because absence. Part of
my life's journey took me away and continues
to take me away from my children quite a bit.
There's that great moment in one of the Austin
Powers movies, daddy wasn't there. Remember that?
We all love the Austin Powers in our family and
it's part of being a Ferguson that you watch the
Austin Power movies, you watch the Austin Powers
movies much earlier than is appropriate. But I've
been away a lot. I mean, I was so negligent as
to take a job in the United States in 2002 or
thereabouts when I had three children in school
in England and my then wife wouldn't move. And
I remember saying, "Well, if I stay, if I don't
go, I'll regret it, so I'll commute." And that was
a little bit crazy and I wouldn't advise anybody
to do that. It meant that I was away quite a lot.
It probably made the breakdown
of the marriage inevitable.
So I think my older children would all
agree that they didn't see enough of me and
I've had to compensate for those absences
by trying to be present in other ways,
so it's difficult. I think the truth is that
if you are trying to lead three careers,
as you said at the beginning, if you're trying
to do good academic work and at the same time
engage in some kind of public life
and then also do all this advising,
sure you're going to work 17 hour
days and you'll be in New York
and Washington and London and I used to travel to
the point of insanity prior to the pandemic and
then the pandemic stopped that, forced me to stop
and for a year I lived in Montana and I didn't
travel more than about five miles from the house.
And so I saw the two younger children every day
and it was wonderful. It was wonderful. My now
10-year-old and I would go for a walk every day.
We called it the philosophical walk and it was
after he'd done with his schoolwork and I had
sort of done enough work on my then current book
and we would just have a walk and I wasn't doing
that before and I'm doing it less now, so no, I'm
not going to get great. But the test is always,
are your children going to turn to you in the
moment of crisis? Are they going to tell you
the good news when there is good news? Are you
able to remain in contact even when there's a
great distance geographically between you?
And on that basis, I think I get a B plus.
And I would say to anybody who's highly
motivated, super-driven, type-A personality,
do what you have to do, but remember
the relationship that you have with
your children is more important than anything
else. And on your tombstone, it doesn't say
“wrote 150 emails a day, or closed X
deals,” or it doesn't say “published 16
books.” That's not what the gravestones say.
They talk about whether you were a good son,
whether you were a good husband and whether
you were a good father. That's the gravestone.
People forget that, but that's the gravestone.
Tim Ferriss: So mortality is as good a stepping
stone as any to the next question, which is also
related to parenting, and this may be a set of
comments that are locked in the amber that you
would revise. So I'd be curious to hear your
thoughts. So here goes, it seems that based on
some of the reading I've done several things,
one is that you have been inoculated against
religious faith yourself on some level, but two,
that you believe your children should understand
the Christian frameworks since, and I think the
quote you used, it is still the operating
system of North America and most of Europe.
Would you mind saying more about that? Is
that a misquote? Did I find that on the
Daily Beast? I don't think so. I don't think so.
Niall Ferguson: Most reliable source. Yeah. No, I
was brought up an atheist. My
parents left the Church of Scotland,
Presbyterian established church in Scotland,
mainly I think because of the sectarianism that
was rife in Glasgow, the enmity between Protestant
and Catholics, which dominated the culture of the
city in their day. And also because as scientists,
they embraced a kind of robust enlightenment
skepticism about religion and this was therefore
not a decision that I took. We just didn't go to
church. And when we talked about those questions,
my mother would say, "Life is a cosmic accident,
deal with it." So that was how I was raised.
Tim Ferriss: High five, go out and play.
Niall Ferguson: And in practice my parents
were still Presbyterians. We had all the
kind of classic Calvinist behaviors,
work ethic, all that stuff, deferred
consumption feeling of superiority, which I
think is inherent in being a member of the
elect. Just there was no God, no afterlife. And at
the point of death, your body began to decompose.
Tim Ferriss: All the duty
without any of the payoff.
Niall Ferguson: So ultimately it worked for me and
I don't think there's any kind of way I could find
a religious faith, I would feel a phony. On the
other hand, I don't think it's a good operating
system for a society and all attempts to build a
society on atheism have produced terrible horrors.
I mean, think Soviet Union, anti-clericalism,
anti-Christianity doesn't have a great record.
So I came to the position partly under the
influence of Oxford, religious observance
as opposed to belief is very beautiful in
Oxford in Cambridge perhaps more beautiful
than anywhere else. The choral tradition in
Anglicanism is one of my favorite things.
And I think it offers not only some kind
of consolation, but it also offers social
connections that you won't form in the workplace.
So I came around to believing that although I
didn't have religious faith, I should take my
children to church and I should make sure that
they were educated in Christianity and indeed
in other belief systems, but that Christianity
would be the leading faith in our lives because
it's the leading faith in our civilization still.
And it's silly to be ignorant of it. It
is the operating system. Tom Holland has
this terrific book, Dominion, which points
out that although we think we are secular,
in reality, we are still a
highly Christian society. And
I think that's dead right. So everything gets
colored by the assumptions of Christianity, even
the discussions on issues like climate change,
which are supposed to be scientific in truth,
fears of the apocalypse, the millenarian mindset
are deeply rooted in Christianity. So I think
it's a slightly odd position, but not
without its precedent to be in a church
without real faith, but with a kind of respect
for religious observance and a hope that the
ethical legacy of Jesus Christ does not go
extinct, because I don't think you become a
good person spontaneously as a result of Darwinian
natural selection. No, that's just not plausible.
And so if you can use the Bible as a way of
helping your children find their way to being
good, then I think that's to be encouraged,
even if you were as skeptical as I am about
the existence of God, the possibility
of an afterlife, all the rest of it.
Tim Ferriss: So you mentioned earlier Hitch,
one of your friends, and as you described this,
what I would love to know is did you explicitly
explain to your kids when you took them to church,
what you were doing? In other words, there's
historical significance to this. I don't
believe we're automatically shaped into good moral
human beings by evolutionary pressure, therefore
this is why I'm taking you to church. Or did
you simply expose them and run the risk of
them becoming die-hards and sort of engendering
a lifetime of headbutting with your children? How
explicit or non explicit did you make things?
Niall Ferguson: I'm very explicit about
things like that. I think children
shouldn't be treated as children,
which will sound slightly paradoxical, but it's
a good idea to treat your children as intelligent
mini adults. And I'm sure Thomas, who's 10,
understood it once. I'm not sure Campbell knew
what I was talking about, but he's only five. So
no, I think I'm clear about this and we talk about
it. Look, we have a very interesting religious
heritage as a family. My wife Ayaan is ex-Muslim,
an apostate, who left the religion that she
was brought up in having had a period of devote
adherence as a young girl. So we come at religion
in a kind of unusual way. And so these things do
get discussed. And Thomas is a very articulate
boy. So it would be impossible to take him
to a church without there being some initial
discussion and explicit analysis of motive.
Tim Ferriss: So you mentioned Ayaan,
so we might as well mention her again, Ayaan Hirsi
Ali, people should look this name up. How has your
time with Ayaan changed how you view
Western philosophy? Maybe even view
the world or reality per se? I have to imagine,
I mean, just given her life's experience,
her trajectory that is so difficult for either
— I'll speak for myself, for me to envision in
any experiential way, how has your time with her
affected how you view things? I know that's a very
broad question, but I'm going to leave it broad.
Niall Ferguson: Anybody who hasn't read
one of my wife's books should do something about
that. Ayaan Hirsi Ali, Infidel is a pretty good
place to start. That's her life story, her early
life story, which gives you a sense of what it was
to grow up as a girl in Islam, in Somalia, to live
in Saudi Arabia, to live in Kenya, to experience
radicalization, to be a member of the Muslim
Brotherhood, and then to go to the Netherlands
to escape an arranged marriage, to gradually be
exposed to Western freedoms, to begin to question
faith, eventually to lose that faith, to become
embroiled in the controversies that followed 9/11,
to become a national figure in the Netherlands,
a member of parliament, then to be the target
of a Fatwa, of death threats. All of this is
in there, and it's an extraordinary story.
I've learned that the story there, which
is startling and memorable in many ways
is the tip of an iceberg, a very deep trauma,
I think that's the only way to describe it.
And we're still kind of learning about
that and learning how to deal with it.
So for somebody like me who led a happy life
in a loving family where I was given every
encouragement, it's humbling to think
of a life so different, so much harder
and to realize that that's the life of millions
and millions of girls all over the world.
So that's point one. Point two is, and
I dedicated the book Civilization to
Ayaan for this reason, we take for granted
the freedoms that we are given at birth,
and it's very hard not to take them for granted
if you grew up with the freedom of speech and
political freedom, the freedom to organize, the
freedom of association, all of those freedoms.
But when you get to know and love somebody who
didn't have those things and had to be persuaded
by experience of their value, then you see things
in a different light. And I learned more about the
value of the enlightenment from my Ayaan than
I could have learned from any other source.
and that's partly why Civilization's dedicated to
her, because you've got to see the benefits of a
free society with the eyes of somebody who's lived
under unfreedom, with all the discrimination,
the handicaps of being a girl in a strictly
Muslim society, fully to appreciate them.
Tim Ferriss: I'd second the recommendation on the
read. The story is really mean beyond remarkable.
That's an understatement. And you mentioned the
fatwa. How do you both relate to safety and fear?
How do you think about how much weight to give to
fear of what could happen? And I ask, especially
in light of the not so distant attack on Salman
Rushdie as an example, right? It's not like
fatwas are just forgotten. It would seem, I know
there's a lot of coverage around that and many
different takes. But how do you think about
living life and how much weight to give to fear,
what could happen versus other factors?
Niall Ferguson: Well, I wouldn't speak for
Ayaan. It would be untrue for me to claim that she
doesn't feel fear. No, the attack on Salman
Rushdie was a heavy blow for us because it
was a reminder that these death threats don't have
expiry dates. There's no statute of limitations.
But fear, I'll answer on my
own behalf, is not a factor.
I don't fear these people. And I
credit that to a Scottish upbringing.
My grandfathers faced far
greater peril in the world wars.
My father's father served on the Western front
in one of the highland regiments as a teenager.
And my mother's father was in Burma with
the Royal Air Force fighting the Japanese.
They had reasons to feel fear. I don't, and
I have a complete contempt for terrorists
that is not fake. I moved to the United States
after 9/11 because I was supposed to give us a
lecture at NYU on, I think it was 9/12. And of
course I never gave that lecture, couldn't fly,
but it kind of made my mind up to move to the US
and to take a job at NYU, which is what I did. I
resigned from Oxford shortly after 9/11. I don't
think I thought it through quite at the time,
but it was undoubtedly the Scottish impulse
to march towards the sound of gunfire.
And ever since I've known Ayaan,
I've felt a powerful obligation to protect
her and make sure that she is kept safe,
but never fear. Because historically, we face
many dangers. One can see that the world is much
less dangerous than it was in many respects, and
in other respects, more dangerous than it's ever
beaten. They didn't have to worry about nuclear
war. The risks of catastrophe are in some ways
elevated by the advance of science and in other
ways, science is reducing our vulnerability,
extending our lifespans, giving us a
shot, even if we're diagnosed with cancer.
And I keep telling her and others the dangers that
we face include terrorists, but the probability
is probably higher that we have
an automobile accident or one
of us gets diagnosed with cancer,
so be not afraid. And the culture,
which I love about my part of the world, the
culture of Scotland, is we don't feel fear.
You can do anything to us, but you can actually
frighten us. And if you're brought up with that,
if that sort of really drummed into you,
that's a great source of strength.
Of course, one fears odd things.
I've always been more afraid of losing my
reputation or my honor than losing my life.
But the things that the terrorists want to
induce, the kind of fear they want to induce,
that is entirely foreign to me and I defy them and
I despise them. And I will use everything I can do
to thwart them, because ultimately their threat
is a, it's a threat that you can thwart. Salman
Rushdie made a terrible mistake in announcing that
he was dispensing with security and saying, at the
time, he published his last book, "I need to live
my life." I said at the time, that was a mistake
and it was. That is not our
approach, but no fear, no way.
Tim Ferriss: Thank you for answering that.
Niall, we've covered a lot of ground.
Is there anything else that you would like to
share, discuss? Any closing comments, anything at
all you'd like to request of people listening,
anything you'd like to point their attention
to before we wind this round one to a close?
Niall Ferguson: Given that the risk of cancer
is not trivial when you're a 58 year old Scotsman,
I don't have anything else to say because if I say
anything else, I'll be late for my dermatological
appointment. So on the basis of rational
assessment of risk, I really better shut up.
Tim Ferriss: I must go to my dermatologist, which
makes perfect sense. Niall, and just for people
listening who don't get the visual spelling here,
N-I-A-L-L on Twitter @Nfergus N-F-E-R-G-U-S. Thank
you so much for taking the time today. I learned
a lot. I have copious notes, I have many things
to follow up on, and it's nice to see you again.
So thank you for making the time.
Niall Ferguson: Thank you, Tim.
Tim Ferriss: And for everybody listening, we
will link to everything that we discussed,
all of the books, all of the resources, anything
and everything at tim.blog/podcast. Just search
Ferguson or Niall, N-I-A-L-L, and it will
take you right there. Until next time, be
just a little bit kinder than is necessary. Take
care. Do not be afraid. And thanks for listening.